cards
[Laughter]
[Music]
this has been requested many many times
on the jkig and the Discord so sure
about that I think it's only right that
we finally watch this oh are you sure
about that yeah
Colleen how's it make you feel why are
you laughing so much Celine yo she looks
like she could be your sister
[Music]
dang look at them jam into it
dude the sound quality is so good
[Laughter]
[Music]
the faces she makes in this character
are probably one of the funniest things
yo is that an Asian girl right yeah yeah
yeah bro you know what she you know what
this you know what this event is she's
like it's a promotion for a Murphy bed
for a Murphy bed that she she's got her
own brand of like weights yeah what's a
Murphy bed yeah
you can put into the wall so she's got a
furniture store she has a product yeah
well she would herself was a content
creator a YouTuber and then she she
built a Furniture yeah I have questions
why this song why not this song Wait
keep going
does she say furniture at the end she
never ties in the furniture around at
all this original it is an original so
what happened is that she started making
like content on YouTube and uh she made
this character and it slowly grew into
this oh it's a character yeah what was
the character like a racist character
her being like like really it's just
like this ninja character that like oh
so it's purely a ninja well she created
like the like there's two characters
there's this villain named Chao who
she's singing about okay that's why she
says I want to chop chop chop Chow Down
take ciao down to Chinatown she's like
the narrative is that she's defeating
this evil actual Asian guy she built a
really complicated like Murphy Cinematic
Universe yes
so it's it's by the Murphy bed like when
does the Murphy bed come in it's she's
got it you want to buy one no but like
how is it integrated into this music
video is it Ninja themed no it's not at
all is it Black Sheets it's just like
she just makes these like funny videos
and like funny characters this is just
one of her this makes these people
listen to it these are the people that
are there for like the Murphy bed event
or something and she's performing for
them can you imagine how [__] funny
that must been like you're like hey
um I'm debuting this new car please come
to my event right and everyone comes and
they're like [__] I can't wait to see
what this car is gonna be yeah
hey imagine that Elon Musk did that at a
Tesla event
[__] cyber trucks I am
okay they're like what does that have to
do with the truck bro
for real I want to be gay guy
I go to San Francisco it was Hollywood
why are you still Asian I don't know and
you're there to support the truck you're
like um they must have been so confused
like all the ladies are like like oh
cool this one folds out this one's pink
whatever and she goes ladies and
gentlemen gather around gather around
and then they're like oh we're gonna
hear about the Murphy bed and she goes I
want to be ninja I think it's very
important to note that um she is highly
Unapologetic about this she completely
is just like her stance on it is very
much like
what it's just a joke and it's like
she's been she's been on other podcasts
like talking of course like Bobby Lee
and uh Santino talk to her actual face
to face like they brought her on well
they brought her on like uh she calls in
and they talk to her about it and she
really is like well other comedians can
make accents why can't I and it's like
there's some things that are like okay I
get it but you're this is not the same
thing like this is so different it is
but just to show how how committed she
is to this thing here is a movie teaser
for the movie I want to be in oh nice
let's watch it this was uploaded two
weeks ago oh oh this is recent so this
is is this after tiger belly this is
after or after after all that after all
of that yeah
oh hell yeah
she's a Superhero yo she has a pink
she's still pink
so she's still married to this idea
is that ciao that's ciao
Smiles
he's trying to end Smiles huh
half a billion she's laying into it
pretty hard to experience the stuff no
one's a fan of this no one's a fan of
this no one's a true fan of this this is
so stupid who's gonna watch it okay do
you have a patreon link on his side up
as a filmmaker
you gotta say one thing
whose side are you on dude what do you
think of this project is it I mean
someone is in film it looks self-funded
that original ninja video like of her
singing at that event has 2.6 million
views over two years
which I feel like is gonna keep growing
oh yeah but yeah but what are the
billions of fans Dude where's that I
don't know I think that's across all
platforms and like across all the people
who have commented on it on their
channels Tim Dylan my feelings aren't
hurt about it or like the other Asians
feelings hurt well because you brought
up a good point when we were talking
about it remember you were like saying
you were like saying it's not as
insulting to Asians as it is making her
looks too yeah she just looks stupid
that's what I thought I'm like okay for
Asians that do get insulted right I'm
like isn't it funnier the fact that she
made this yeah because because the
person like how do you explain it it's
like this person is so
like dumb like there's no like that like
if she if she this is a clearer
statement than her railing out a window
I'm [__] this is even more clear
than that I have brain damage I'm like
that's like that it doesn't really hurt
my feelings I'm like okay to me this
this doesn't make like Asians look bad
this makes white people look mad it
makes her look crazy right sure yes are
you embarrassed absolutely as a as a as
a blonde female how would you make the
song better yeah
I wouldn't make it you wouldn't who
would you say if she was your friend and
she sent you the link it was like can
you share I don't think her and I would
be friends
what would you run ninja yeah
Ninja
[Laughter]
yeah
I mean I think when a lot of people
would seem to be upset about is the fact
that she's very unbothered and kind of
unaffected financially but well I'll say
this you could see by the way she's
singing and the excitement of her face
and then the dead eyes on the rest of
the room she's crazy she's nuts she's
absolutely crazy and I think she I also
want to think about like who's editing
that like
like
that's my company Justice edited this
she has if she has an Asian friend like
that homeboy the Chow dude I mean let's
be real ciao trying to get it in dude
ciao trying to he's trying to hook up I
think child trying to hook up or you
think he's Bannon
he he he's probably been around you know
I mean he's probably been in there you
know good [__] I think the funnier story
to me is her like what what inspired her
to make this listen to her explain some
of the lyrics choices okay that she had
so she's trying to explain some of the
lyrics on thing it might be a little
hard to hear but
and I just have this little riff that's
kind of come to me she's talking like
she's Drake
[Music]
she's serious bro she's talking like
she's [__] biggie dude I don't know
it's just hilarious yeah she's crazy
she's crazy she's nuts what if she's
like completely trolling with it I think
she's a genius troll that's highest
level highest level and I think most
people don't commit to that
so I think it's real I don't think Jake
Paul could pull that off I know her
explanation sounds like Kanye yeah you
know what I mean like it sounds like
like yeah she lost her Marbles and she's
like yeah
and people like dude that was bars he's
like yeah yeah yeah it was he's like no
write it down that means she's got a
whole community of people with the same
mentality behind her like yo you're
killing it yeah this is gold yeah people
need to hear about this that kind of
does but then also in her mind if she
puts this song out and it gets 2.6
million views is she wrong she kind of
right is she kind of right that this is
she was even like because you know she's
just Chinatown and then people were
telling her bro like ninjas are from
[__] Japan and she's like well I know
I'm not an expert at geography good
answer bro that's a good [__] yo I
think she's a genius like she's leaning
into her dumb she's good she's good and
then to top it off she films like
another video uh like a visual like sort
of like
you to go with it and she films it in
China
all the way in China she goes all the
way to how does she have so much money
you already got told it was Japanese but
you went to China she's like yeah well I
was in China so oh for her I was like
well I'm already here building Murphy
Beds so she's like I'm meeting with the
warehouse that makes my couches yeah
might as well get some b-roll on the
Great Wall so what if Chow is one of the
guys that worked at the manufacturer in
China Mr partner yeah it's her partner
for the thing yeah but I think what you
said is like I never heard anyone quite
put it that way but I think that's the
easiest
um reference it's like some people
can look so much dubber than the people
that they're making fun of that yeah
that takes precedence it's like it's
like it's not hurting the people as much
as it is wow you're redefining your
sanity to the world yeah my question is
for you guys do you think she's really
trying to make fun of Asian people or do
you think that she just is so like not
on this planet whatever the [__] that is
yeah I don't think she's actually trying
to hurt Asians or make fun of them I
think she's just that unattached yeah
yeah she's really ambitious though to me
the way I enjoy Steven Seagal and his
daughter oh yeah yeah and then like
I see that as her right so if Steven
Seagal makes like another action movie
I love how he takes it so seriously and
he might do something stupid like go
into a Vietnam Village and rescue
everybody and you know he does the whole
Pocahontas thing or The Last Samurai
thing and then everyone might get mad
they're like oh how dare he another
straight white male with the colonizer
effect right and I'm like you're getting
mad at Steven Seagal dude like that's
we're laughing at him for doing he's not
all there he's mentally handicapped
practically we're laughing at the re
that at the idea that they think they're
great and then so I think this is the
the the thing is like what delusional
person
uh debuting a Murphy bed would have a
music performance about being a ninja
that's pretty funny dude yeah that's
amazing she's also been invited to
perform that live on stage at like
conferences and events that are like
more or less Asian like it looks kind of
crazy dude you know what it is it's
entertainment I don't think it's the
content it's her and the energy she's
putting towards it the ambition is what
people are like oh she's onto something
she's a performer dude they want her
like like she's got that she's like
obviously different but then she's got
that something that people want because
look at look at all the [__] that's
happening now she's blowing up that's
true yeah but is she blowing up the
right reasons though so cringy that
that's why those are other content yeah
what what is she known for vlogger or
like a beauty person yeah the fact that
she could sell a Murphy bed it's so it's
just so odd like everything about her is
just so like at a left field wait you
said that she was inspired by Ryan Hugo
right she said her right her whole story
about it is that she was shown like back
in the day how to be a ninja by Ryan
Higa and she thought it was so funny
that she's like oh how to be a ninja I
can be the ninja and then it just gave
birth to this like so this is Ryan
higa's fault so she could be ninja too I
like that guy though I could be ninja
too I mean she just makes a lot of like
little characters and like kind of like
goofy stuff how's her other stuff what
does she do she has a lot of stuff dude
look at her eyes bro look at her eyes
she's the only followers does she have
she looks yeah look she has a lot of
videos through the years yeah so how
many followers she's been uh she's an
old school YouTuber right yeah I guess
sort of maybe I mean if she's
if she's inspired by Higa I mean sure
she's like
she want to be ninja well she started
her account in 2012 so catchy it's kind
of catchy I was saying it all day
yesterday she has 44k subscribers
I think that's where some people are mad
is they're mad at like well it's not so
much like some people aren't gonna be
mad at her they're mad at what she
created as far as then it encourages
other people to make fun of you like you
might walk down the street and some
random guy's gonna go I want to be mean
John you're gonna be like [__] but also
if you're on game it's like it's less
about it being Asian and more about it
being like internet culture because like
this video is more about like like it's
a meme it's kind of a meme bro I think
in my mind she did pronounce ninja
correctly ninja
she did you gotta get both e's in there
yeah but she spells it that way for her
Brandon too it's spelled ninja but my
whole thing is like as a brand for
Murphy Beds
like how does this all fit I actually
want to see the Murphy bed like I'm
actually curious no honestly the Murphy
bed is kind of tight because she shows I
love Murphy Beds I like Murphy Beds
they're cool look Jennifer Murphy Beds
all right we'll do her solid and plug
her actual problems yeah we'll play yeah
she has Murphy Beds you can check it out
completely unrelated from her ninja
Masterpiece I'll show you the Murphy bed
but she should get help I think she
should that's the most do you think
she's actually mentally ill I think so
either ultimate troll or her marbles are
gone yeah ultimate troll she went in but
if she if her marbles are gone she
should get some help I think I love how
she doubled down though that's hilarious
what does the next shark comments have
to say about her everyone hates her for
sure yeah right here
she sleeps in it every night
but look how much more space she had
right like that didn't the ninja pops
out
that would have been a way better tie-in
and then they break out to a fight scene
yeah
so am I actually what do you think is it
a space saver it is it is but those eyes
have nothing behind them
you don't think she has death
that's not even that I just think she
she
foreign